künstliche intelligenz wenn maschinen
immer schlauer werden
das könnten wir mit unserer eigenen
hirnleistung machen wenn wir das hier
mit einer schleifmaschine koppeln um so
etwas wie eine super intelligenz zu
erreichen stellte ich hole könnte einen
computer oder avatar mit euren gedanken
steuer oder andersrum stellt euch vor
ihr könntet von einem computer neue
skills auf bayer gehirn solche visionen
haben nicht nur hollywood filmemacher
sondern zum beispiel auch elon musk der
real life tony stark man kennt ihn
wahrscheinlich am ehesten von tester
oder space sechs heute reden wir mal
über seine firma jura link mit der er
vor ein paar monaten dieses preprint
paper ausgebracht hat hier wird eine
neue hardware vorgestellt die als
schnittstelle zwischen gehirn und
maschine dienen solche schnittstellen
auch brain machine interfaces genannt
wurden aber nicht von ihrer maß gefunden
sondern wären schon eine ganze weile
lang erforscht brain machine interfaces
werden übrigens genauso abgekürzt wie
der body mass index nämlich mit bmi
reden wir also heute mal über die
spannendere bedeute von bmi und schauen
wir uns an was heute bereits mit babys
möglich ist und so viel verraten schon
mal es ist mehr als wahrscheinlich denkt
[Musik]
erst mal die basics wie funktionieren
brain machine interfaces unser gehirn
steht unter strom die nervenzellen also
die neurone leiten informationen in form
von elektrischen signalen weit
vergleichen wir das mal mit dem strom
den wir aus einer batterie kennen eine
geladene batterie steht unter
elektrischer spannung das ist das was in
volt angegeben wird diese spannung kann
man sich vereinfacht vorstellen wie ein
ungleichgewicht zwischen elektrischen
ladungen also die ganze negativ
geladenen elektronen sitzen am minuspol
am pluspol sitzen keine und dadurch
entsteht eine elektrische spannung
zwischen diesen beiden polen verbindet
man jetzt die beiden pole mit einem
kabel fließen die elektronen von dennis
pohl zum pluspol um diese spannung
auszugleichen und somit haben wir strom
bei den neuronen im hirn dienen
spannungs änderungen
als signale also zur übertragung von
informationen und es fließen hier zwar
keine elektronen aber andere geladene
teilchen also ionen nur der mechanismus
dieser signalweiterleitung ist ein
bisschen komplexer als strom der jetzt
einfach nur durch ein kabel fließt in
der membran der neurone befinden sich
kleine kanäle diese kanäle öffnen sich
denn es an der membran einen spannungs
impuls gibt sprich wenn sich die
spannung zwischen innen und außen ändert
durch diese geöffneten kanäle fließen
jetzt jungen in die nervenzelle hinein
und sorgen damit wieder für eine
spannung signal das benachbarte kanäle
dazu bringt sich zu öffnen und die
stoßen dann wiederum benachbarte kanäle
an und so weiter und so wandert das
signal man sagt auch dass
aktionspotenzial wie eine la ola welle
die zellmembranen land so da jetzt
gehirnaktivität im grunde auf
elektrischen spannungsimpulse basiert
kammern gehirnaktivität ablesen
indem man diese elektrischen impulse
mist oder andersrum man kann
gehirnaktivität stimulieren indem man
entsprechende impulse rhein gibt genau
das machen babys dazu muss man nur
elektronen mit dem computer verbinden
und sich dann diese elektronen
intrigiert stecken ja diese invasive
methode ist notwendig um eine
ausreichend gute auflösung zu bekommen
also um die signale viele einzelner
neurone klar voneinander trennen zu
können
andernfalls kann man keine komplexen
inhalte kommunizieren es gibt auch nicht
invasive methoden mit denen man von
außen also durch die kopfhaut und den
schädel die genaktivität messen oder
auch beeinflussen kann die eeg also
elektroenzephalografie oder die
transkranielle magnetstimulation aber da
diese messungen oder stimulationen
ziemlich weit entfernt sind von den
neuronen ist die auflösung
lisa also man misst oder stimuliert
immer millionen hier in zellen
gleichzeitig das ist wie tippen mit dem
boxhandschuh deshalb forschung
hauptsächlich an invasiven methoden man
hat im gehirn zwar kein schmerzempfinden
das ist schon mal ein vorteil wenn man
sich da was rein stecken möchte aber
ungefährlich ist es auch nicht dazu
kommen wir auch gleich noch schauen wir
erstmal wie weit man bisher in der
forschung gekommen ist denn die
experimente ist in echt abgefahren
brain machine interfaces in der
forschung beispiel eines sinnes
erweiterung durch bmi stellt euch vor
ihr könntet unsichtbare strahlung sehen
ist von unseren farben video dass wir
nicht nur in einem kleinen
wellenlängenbereich sehen können iv
licht oder infrarot licht ist unsichtbar
für uns für ratten übrigens auch doch
die forschungsgruppe rundum
neurowissenschaftler miguel nicole elis
hatten die fähigkeit gegeben infrarotes
licht zu erfüllen
zunächst arbeiteten die forscher mit
normalem sichtbaren licht sie
versteckten eine belohnung für die rate
bei einem licht und brachten so der rate
bei zu diesem licht zu laufen um sich
die belohnung zu holen konnten sie jetzt
den ratten auch beibringen zu einem
unsichtbaren licht zu laufen zu
infrarotlicht dafür implantierte man den
ratten einen infrarotsensor auf den kopf
der computer übersetzte jetzt das
infrarotlicht in eine elektrische pulse
sie also in künstliche aktionspotenziale
je intensiver das licht desto größer die
pulsfrequenz diese impulse wurden dann
über elektroden in das gehirn der
ratsche übertragen und zwar in den
sogenannten summarischen cortex das ist
dieselbe hirnregion die auch die taste
bewegung registriert der infrarotsensor
auf dem kopf kommt es also für die
ratten das unsichtbare licht durch
entsprechende hier in signale spürbar
machen dann wiederholte mal mit den
ratten das belohnungs experiment nur
dieses mal verriet nur infrarotlicht wo
sich die belohnung versteckte und
tatsächlich nach einem monat training
konnten die ratten dank bmi die
belohnung
buchstäblich aufspüren ihr raten bekamen
somit durch dieses brain machine
interface eine sinnes erweiterung aber
es geht noch krasser beispiel zwei
prothesen steuerung durch babys diese
bewegungen steuerlich ja gerade alle mit
meinem gehirn
jetzt stelle ich für euch könnte einen
externen roboterarm genau wie meinen
eigenen abend über magiern steuern es
gibt ein experiment das schon 2003
durchgeführt wurde aber immer noch der
absolute milow ist die forscher brachten
einem affen ein einfaches computerspiel
bei dem er einen roboter abend bewegen
musste und zwar über einen joystick die
forscher zeichnete nun die bewegung des
joysticks zusammen mit der
gehirnaktivität des affen auf ein
maschinen learning algorithmus lernt nun
welche joystick bewegung mit welcher
hirn aktivität korrelierte und
irgendwann konnte der computer die
gehirnaktivität lesen als er konnte auf
basis der hirnaktivität die joystick
bewegung voraussagen und dass das auch
funktioniert konnten die forscher zeigen
indem sie dem joystick von dem
roboterarm trennten zu dass der
roboterarm nicht mehr durch den joystick
gesteuert werden konnte
stattdessen koppelten die forscher den
roboter haben direkt an das gehirn des
affen über diese schnittstelle die eben
hier in signale in bewegung übersetzt
und so konnte der affe das spiel
weiterspielen noch krasser ist dass der
von einer zeit sogar merkte dass er den
joystick gar nicht mehr braucht und dass
er sein spiel an
unabhängig davon bewegen konnte und
spielte das spiel ganz einfach mit
seinen gedanken weiter wie mir hätte
dieses experiment auf jeden fall nicht
funktioniert weil ich ja niemals auf die
idee kommen würde dass ich irgendwas
ohne meine hände bewegen kann
der affe hingegen so hat den joystick
den brauch jetzt anscheinend ich gut
dann spielt das spiel einfach mit meinen
gedanken wollte
no big deal beispiel drei
gedankenübertragung durch babys in
unserem ersten beispiel haben wir
gesehen dass eine ratte ein
eingangssignal
von einem bmi als anweisung
interpretieren kann was sie jetzt tun
soll im zweiten beispiel konnte ein affe
lernen eine prothese wir hier in
anweisungen zu bedienen indem er eine
entsprechende rückmeldung bekam also ein
feedback jetzt kombinieren wir diese
zwei prinzipien um zwei tiere über einen
brain machine interface miteinander zu
verknüpfen in diesem spektakulären
experiment schaffte man so etwas wie
eine gedankenübertragung zwischen zwei
raten die zwei raten saßen in zwei
verschiedenen boxen und konnten sich
nicht sehen
ratti nummer eins setzte man vor zwei
hebel von denen sie einen drücken musste
um eine belohnung zu erhalten
ein licht zeigte der ratte an welchen
hebeln sie drücken sollte und wenn sie
den richtigen höhe bedruckte bekam sie
eben die belohnung die hier in aktivität
von drathen nummer eins wurde über
elektroden von einem computer
aufgezeichnet und in spannungssignale
umgesetzt also in anweisungen für ratten
nummer zwei die saß nämlich in der
anderen box hatte auch zwei hebel vor
sich und eine mögliche belohnung nur sie
hatte kein licht das sie an zeigte
welcher hebel der richtige war
stattdessen bekam sie die entsprechenden
tools signale der anderen ratte wie
elektrode in ihr gehirn gesendet und
musste das interpretieren musste also
lernen welcher hebel jetzt der richtige
ist darf man sich das nicht so
vorstellen dass die rate da sitzt diese
signale bekommt und dann sofort checkt
rechts ist also die belohnung wir können
eigentlich gar nicht wirklich
nachvollziehen wie sich diese gedanken
eingabe für die ratte anfühlt aber durch
training kann die ratte lernen diese
impulse die sie von dem bmi bekommt zu
unterscheiden und sie mit den
verschiedenen hebeln zu verknüpfen also
so ähnlich wie auch die rate mit dem
infrarot sensor lernt diese impulse zu
interpretieren aber noch krasser ist
eigentlich das auch ratte nummer eins
mit der zeit lernt ihre hier in
anweisungen immer präziser zu geben
genauso wie der affe mit der zeit lernt
den roboterarm immer präziser zu
bedienen wenn die nummer zwei
nämlich den richtigen hebel drückte dann
bekam rate nummer eins eine zweite
belohnung nur diese belohnung diente als
feedback für diese ratte die so lernen
konnte ein immer deutlicheres signal
rauszugeben beide hatten passten also
ihre gehirnaktivität und ihr verhalten
an diese bmi gestützte verbindungen
das waren jetzt nur drei von vielen
beispielen also es gibt inzwischen
einige faszinierende und erfolgreiche
versuche mit dem es heißt dass stehen
kurz vor dem durchbruch die
anwendbarkeit von bmi forschungen
theorie alles faszinierend keine frage
nur wie lässt sich das alles nun
wirklich auf die praxis übertragen
hier gibt es drei probleme erstens die
komplexität des signals all unseren
forschungs beispielen wurden nun sehr
komplexe signale von sehr vielen euronen
in ein stark vereinfachtes
ausgangssignal übersetzt oder andersrum
es wurden sehr stark vereinfachte puls
muster auf ganz viele neuronen
gleichzeitig übertragen und trotz dieser
starken vereinfachung brauchen die tiere
monatelanges training um sich mit den
babys umzugehen die vision dass wir mit
unserem gehirn komplexe maschinen
steuern dass wir uns mit einer
virtuellen realität verbinden
miteinander sprachlos kommunizieren oder
zum beispiel über einen bmi eine neue
sprache auf unser gehirn laden davon
sind wir derzeit noch sehr weit entfernt
tippen wir heute vielleicht nicht mehr
mit dem boxhandschuh aber mindestens
noch mit fäustlingen herkömmliche
schnittstellen die jetzt unsere sprache
unsere hände unsere sinnesorgane mit
denen wir miteinander oder auch mit
computern kommunizieren sind viel
effizienter und komplexer als die
modernsten babys für menschen die aber
zum beispiel gelehnt sind können auch
sehr einfache funktionen einen großen
unterschied für ihre lebensqualität
machen
beispiel den schirm sie ist vom hals
abwärts gelähmt 2012 nahmen sie sehr
enthusiastisch an einem
forschungsprojekt der university of
pittsburgh teil in dem ein baby
gesteuerter roboterarm für menschen
entwickelt wurde
hier sieht man sehen wie
mit hilfe eines implantierten babys so
ein roboterarm steuert um wieder
selbstständig essen zu können
[Musik]
aber hier gibt es das zweite große
problem haltbarkeit ein dauerhaftes
implantat kann gesundheitliche probleme
verursachen das implantat von gentleman
zum beispiel musste nach einer zeit
entfernt werden weil sich die kopfhaut
um einen der sockel zurückzog und die
drähte entblößt wurden und das wurde
dann zu einem infektionsrisiko für ihr
gehirn brain machine interfaces sind
ohnehin nur eine zeit lang nutzbar ein
grund dafür sind die starren elektroden
die mit jeder bewegung des gehirns also
ja das gehirn bewegt sich ständig passiv
im kopf zu kleinen verletzungen und
narbenbildung und führt und das
wachsende narbengewebe kann die
elektrode mit der zeit isolieren so dass
den kontakt verliert in masken über lync
wollen dieses problem mit sogenannten
elektro trends lösen es sind besonders
dünne und flexible elektroden die sich
so die hoffnung mit dem gehirn mit
bewegen zu implantieren dienen außerdem
büro- botter die immerhin an der gehirn
oberfläche verletzungen von blutgefäßen
vermeiden können allerdings wurde bisher
noch nicht erwähnt wie lange diese
elektro trends in ihren bisherigen
versuchen tatsächlich viel es gibt auch
semi invasive methoden zum beispiel kann
man scheiben implantieren die wehren
flach auf die hirnhaut aufgelegt trinken
aber nicht in das gehirn ein
mit so einem system kann dieser 28
jährige querschnittsgelähmte franzose
nun schon seit zwei jahren ein
exoskelett steuern mehr infos dazu in
der video beschreibung allerdings für
den austausch detaillierter
informationen mit hoher bandbreite sowie
ihr dann macht sich das wünscht ist die
auflösung so eines semi invasiven
systems nicht ausreichend aber es gilt
als zweifach konzept das auch langzeit
anwendungen in der prothesen steuerung
möglich sind das könnte menschen mit
querschnittslähmung ihre mobilität
zurückgeben
nur dabei sollten wir auch ein paar
ethische aspekte nicht vergessen ich
vermute jetzt mal die wenigsten von euch
würden sich elektroden ins gehirn
implantieren lassen nur um eine sinnes
erweiterung oder andere spielereien zu
erfahren und selbst eine extrem coole
anwendung sagen wir ich könnte jetzt
über ein bmi alle sprachen der welt
sprechen also das ist wie gesagt nicht
möglich aber sagen wir es wäre es das
wäre der hammer aber würde ich mir dafür
ernsthaft die schädeldecke öffnen und
elektroden ins gehirn stecken lassen
das wirklich jetzt nicht wundern wenn
idealmaß das wirklich machen würde aber
die meisten von uns würden
wahrscheinlich keiner op unterziehen
wenn es keinen ernsthaften medizinischen
bedarf gibt zumal ja jede op auch mit
einem risiko einhergeht aber wenn es
jetzt um anwendungen für menschen mit
behinderung geht die dadurch ihre
mobilität zurückgewinnen könnten würden
die meisten wahrscheinlich sagen das ist
doch super diese anwendung dieser
forschung kann man ja nur unterstützen
naja ich habe mit aktivist raul
krauthausen gesprochen der sich für
menschen mit behinderung einsetzt also
meine perspektive ob das ganze thema
soll dass man sehr vorsichtig sein muss
mit mit solchen meldungen und auch
technologien die person die behinderung
hat wird dafür verantwortlich gemacht
die behinderung aus der welt zu schaffen
in dem sie operiert wird indem sie
therapie macht indem sie ein exoskelett
reck und bestellen viel zu wenig die
frage wie könnte aber auch eine
gesellschaft aussehen in der es okay ist
wenn man eben nicht laufen kann wenn man
eben nicht hören kann also zum beispiel
indem mehr gebärdensprache benutzt wird
indem wir aufzüge und rampen und so
weiter bauen oder bei netflix unter
pickeln dass wir durch neue technologien
ja auch barrieren beseitigen können um
menschen so wie sie sind an der
gesellschaft teilhaben zu lassen
trotzdem bin ich ein großer freund von
technologischen fortschritt auch ich
selber fahre einen elektrischen
rollstuhl der besser ist als ein
manueller rollstuhl weil ich einfach
auch aufgrund meiner behinderung in
meiner körperlichen kraft
einfach riemer ist mit einem manuellen
rollstuhl so weit käme nicht mit dem
elektrischen rollstuhl komme aber auch
da genauer geguckt ist das richtig
traurige technologie da drin da gibt es
null innovationen also es gibt immer nur
da innovationen geld ist also ich als
aktivist für inklusion und
barrierefreiheit bekomme regelmäßig
links geschickt von leuten die mir mein
irgendetwas gutes zu tun in dem sie zum
beispiel nennt link schicken von dem
treppensteigen im rollstuhl oder von
einem handschuh der gebärdensprache in
phone oder text übersetzt und all diese
technologien sind mega fancy aber sie
sind nicht unbedingt günstig die die
krankenkassen beziehung ist
wahrscheinlich nicht bezahlen
das heißt auch hier durch diese neuen
technologien überlassen wir letztendlich
diese ganzen geschichten nur den
privilegierten dem gleichen wie seht ihr
das würdet ihr euch aufwendig implantat
ins gehirn einsetzen lassen und was wäre
die coolste anwendung eines bmi die euch
einfällt wir sehen uns bald bis dahin
bleibt sicher